we want to get right out to madison
kimbrough she's live near charleston and
fremont where that fire erupted early
this morning madison
sasha you can still smell the fire in
the air the smoke in the air take a look
at the scene as it's very graphic you
can see pieces of this apartment
building completely burned to the ground
this fire described as the largest fire
seen in the city in the last 25 years
that's according to las vegas fire and
rescue according to las vegas fire and
rescue at least 10 buildings were
damaged and or destroyed as units
arrived on scene to find a large
building under construction fully
engulfed in flames due to the severity
of the winds a second alarm was
requested for additional crews in total
two more alarms were requested with 40
fire units and 140 fire personnel from
las vegas north las vegas and clark
county arriving on scene here's what one
resident tells us about her unit being
destroyed
there's ashes all over the floor from
where the embers came into the room
thank god those things didn't catch on
fire in that room
so
we got out safe by 6 a.m the majority of
the fire was contained but crews are
expected to be here for the rest of the
day tending to hot spots and flare-ups
several vehicles were also destroyed but
luckily no one was majorly hurt with one
person suffering minor injuries
again about 100 people were evacuated
still waiting to hear how many people
were displaced at this time the red
cross is assisting this fire is still
under investigation reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now